die hre arbeitet apple und kam dafür
gearbeitet bei apple und kamerun und hat
mir ein geburtstagsgeschenk für mich mal
recht der tag damit ich mein niveau
nicht mehr verlieren ist das nicht schön
ja
wir sind schon jetzt
auf jeden fall zum podcast aufnahme
zusammen rat nico
[Musik]
hallo ihr zwei idioten kauft opel haben
die warum sagt man diebstahl und nicht
die aluminium oder die metallteile die
muskeln aus stahl haben wollen leute
weil ich meinen solange nehmen teil
machen dass lukas videos ich hab euch ja
am letzten pass verraten dass sie jetzt
eine freundin habe
ihr werdet jetzt bestimmt öfter sehen ja
den podcast folgen ist es uns übrigens
auch immer wichtig dass wir etwas
gemerkt hat dass man nicht weiß was wir
hier konsumieren wie spotify natürlich
hoffe ich hoffe es auch für uns alle
dass wir natürlich kein krieg haben
außerdem
die so schön dass wir mal wieder mit
mobilem und das längste theke der welt
zu sandra danke auch dass du deine
wohnung nutzen dürfen unseren podcast
aufzunehmen extra dafür als ihre couch
paar kurven seiner torszene licht china
wirklich
boah das ist richtig scheiße das richte
hier muss ein bild in das bild muss auch
angeleuchtet werden ja generell eine
komplett neue küche eigentlich eine neue
wohnung
es gibt nichts schöneres als wenn es
kalt ist und man läuft dann so
geschäften her da kommt so ein bisschen
warme luft raus heißt
ja bitte ich hasse es in der innenstadt
zu locken deswegen berichteten von unten
aber wir gehen jetzt dort hoch einfach
auf kölner dom
wo ich fühle mich so wie national
geographic gerade wenn ich das filmen
teilen aufzug kein scherz das waren
jetzt die ersten 20 treppenstufen es
werden insgesamt ich will nicht googeln
ich bin ich jetzt hier mal ein
was denkst du wie viele es sein werden
ich sage ich glaube nicht so viele mit
620 vj dann braucht man ca
die gefahr ist relativ groß als es mir
nicht gut geht leicht
ich glaube ich glaube wir haben 25
prozent geschafft wir sind schon relativ
hoch eigentlich wenn ich mir angucke
haben doch schon mehr geschafft
jeder der hier hoch läuft fast schon weg
und wir beide 1 erfolgs im letzten block
wandern jetzt besteige ich in kölner dom
weiter die fenster könnten sich aber
wieder putzen
sofern die hälfte der ersten ebene 4 auf
53 metern oder
ich fühle mich schon ein bisschen wie in
rom wo der film
so was macht
[Musik]
wir sind auf jeden fall schon ziemlich
hoch ich wohne seit sieben jahren in
köln
und ich war noch nie auf dem kölner dom
trafo nicht irgendwo ist klar ist der
rein also sandra würden wir auf jeden
fall niemals hochkriegen
es geht noch höher
die mich wie auf eiffelturm bisschen ich
war noch nicht auch mainz kobinet die
letzten treppenstufen und ihr könnt euch
das nicht vorstellen vielleicht hört man
es auch ein bisschen aber es ist
unfassbar will ich das hier stützte
ausblick
er ist krank aber
wieder nach oben ist einfach mal was
abgebrochen
da auch
die sind extra so viele nadeln damit
sich keine vögel hinsetzen damit nichts
vollgeschossen wird das gut klappt soll
ich noch dazu scheiße
ja
juli gitarren sich eigentlich übels
hochwertiger luxuriöser laden in köln
einfach hässlich store der welt ist es
einfach köln kölsch wagen unter 44 ticks
sieglosen keine ahnung was hier los ist
aber
das ist irgendwie die e-scooter straße
in köln 35 e scooter auf einer strecke
von 25 metern so viel stehe nicht mehr
bei sander vor der haustüre guten tag er
hat besser man besser werden ganz köln
francesco wenn du siehst du bist besser
aber gefährt das besser gesagt diese
aufnahme die ich euch jetzt gerade einem
länder haben wir dort gemacht genau hier
jetzt stehen wir hier unten
das war schon hoch also ich liebe
starbucks aber die haben bisher jedes
verdammte mein name falsch geschrieben
hätten ich habe noch nie gesehen wie ein
kran aufgebaut wurde noch nie für mich
war ein kleiner einfach irgendwie da die
spawnen einfach plötzlich genauso wie
jürgen von ihnen jürgen getroffen der
unter 40 ist sie sind einfach da
plötzlich habe geisteskrank und respekt
vor leuten die so nahe an einem
bordstein parkt und man somit der
frontschürze noch darüber dass würde ich
mich niemals trauen dixi klos er hat
einfach einen lena an seinem fahrrad die
entspannt ist es bitter dass gerade so
ein typ mann und ich hasse das mich in
der stadt film habe ich mir das peinlich
es kam so ein typ
der meinen bruder guckt man die
minecraft videos ich muss mich scheiße
oder mit
sie sind also singt schön wenn alle
leute die machen können currywurst essen
wollen dort ist er bislang ich weiß
nicht wieder heiß aber das ist neben
alfredo café bar bekommen da kein geld
für aber ihr wisst ja ich bin
mittlerweile köln touristenführer
sie
hässlich wie ist das digitales
ich finde ich
mittlerweile schon dunkel draußen
und ich bisher ja
du nein ich hab mal gewonnen oder
nein du hast das letzte mal einfach
geschummelt
die steht doch das ist nicht meine
schaufel seite
das ist genau geringer als touristische
übrigens der einzig wahre ice ts nicht
bezahlt trotz man die ihre männer mit
einfach letztes 40 stück von hin
zugeschrieben also man kann ganz easy
einfach sagen hey ist jetzt leider meine
freundin irgendwie dann auch wir sind
zusammen seit 28 zehnter
2021 und
hoffentlich noch park auch und mehr wie
keine ahnung also die sache ist dass ich
das auch schon im podcast gesagt habe
den wir heute aufgenommen haben dadurch
die ganze hintergrundstory immer so ein
bisschen erklärt warum ist geheim
gehalten haben dieser sah das dann ist
mir allerdings aufgefallen dass die
podcast nächste woche donnerstag online
geht das video hier allerdings jetzt
schon heute eine woche vorher deswegen
muss sich zwangsläufig jetzt noch mal
kurz sagen wir haben es lange zeit
geheim gehalten hat nicht so richtig
geklappt weil es irgendwie doch leute
rausgefunden haben weil wir beide
irgendwie auch eine öffentlichkeit
stehen jetzt haben uns allerdings gesagt
dass es irgendwie ein bisschen too much
wird mit dem druck auch so ein bisschen
und dass man
ja und es war auch so dass die dann halt
rausgegangen sind wenn wir unter leuten
waren haben wir immer so getan als wären
wir nicht zusammen da wird das irgendwie
aufrecht halten wollten freunde klar die
wussten alle bescheid aber so vom team
her auf jeden fall kurzfassung wir sind
seit ende oktober zusammen meinen fuß
kann hat die ganze zeit
die ich kenne keinen manager seine ende
so weit auseinander zu machen kann
das einfach keine knochen wäre doch ein
fachgymnasium knochen es ist einfach
runter drücken langfassung werde ich auf
jeden fall noch mal ein podcast erzählen
[Musik]
ja das war
okay jetzt haben die bayerischen sachen
ja
ja ich wollte ja ganz gut sagen dass
jetzt eventuell peyton ab und zu mal ein
bisschen sehen wenn
haben das halt gestern weil wir das hier
seht bevor gestern damit dass auf
instagram einfach nur kurz öffentlich
gemacht und ja wenn ihr jetzt soll ich
jetzt fragt wer das mädchen manchmal
meinen stories ist das ist dann leider
die hier
alle stellen will ich den blog jetzt auf
jeden fall beenden wenn es euch gefallen
hat wie wir den kölner dom hoch gelaufen
sind und bei sandra waren und ich hätte
manchen gestalteten laster hoch dass man
dem kanal klebt auf die glocke und
vielleicht sehen uns bald wieder